[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous
et
[Musique]
oui
nous n'avons placement rien perçu 6
était une fois une aide d'urgence de
1500 euros par une quarantaine pour s'y
être ensemble de gouaille ne ferme pas
et que le niveau de leur part du gâteau
mais pas seulement en train de naviguer
à contre-courant
je suis parfaitement pour en nourrissant
monsieur nous avons décidé d'ouvrir
notre librairie en a conscience et
l'avoir annoncé au gouvernement au
président mal pour lui-même que
j'attends c'est une insulte aux
ministres grise et qui m'a menacé de
fermeture administrative
mais je persiste parce que je considère
qu'ils sont comme vous voyez personne
aujourd'hui un alignement de menhirs
archi pour voir si votre commerce et
vous verrez fermer ses tourments de
commerce est ouvert
[Musique]
je voulais saddam
on
[Musique]